[Music]
hello dear friends and thank you for
joining us today in this program I'd
like to know it is a privilege and an
honor for us to study the Bible together
and we thank you and value your
questions that you sent to us every week
remember that you can send your
questions at the following email address
which is tvam tv.org and once again we
promise you that as we receive the
questions we will respond to you as soon
as we are able to do so today I have
pastor bour with me and Pastor what a
blessing to have you let us start in
this wonderful program with many
questions but before that please lead us
into prayer as we want the Lord to lead
us as we open God's word
let's pray our father and our God so
many questions in this life many times
we don't have answers but we know that
someday we'll be in the Kingdom we'll be
a be able to ask Jesus the questions and
we will receive answers to the questions
that we have no answers for now but we
know that we have uh questions that are
answered in your holy word and so as we
answer these questions that have been
sent to us we we ask that you will guide
our thoughts and our words and that our
comments might be a blessing to those
who are watching this program this we
pray in the precious and Most Holy Name
of Jesus amen amen amen amen pastor we
have a question from the beautiful
country of New Zealand Heather sends us
this question and I'm going to read the
question and we are going to by the
grace of God answer from the word of God
and spirit prophecy the question is this
hello hello to the three of you right
now where's only two of us Pastor CA is
missing for now but he'll be back soon
hello to the three of you my name is
Heather and I live in New Zealand I
watch your program on the different
translations in biblical text this is a
passion of mine I believe where many
many people get things wrong is because
they do not realize that Hebrew like
French has grammatical gender for
example wisdom is Justified of her
children appears several times in the
Bible but we will never think of wisdom
as being a physical woman so why do so
many Christians believe God is a man God
has no physical gender he is in
incorporeal definition definition of
incorporeal having no material existence
I have attached my findings on biblical
translations that I have discovered are
translated incorrectly and sadly the
incorrect translations is the one that
most people believe is true I don't
expect you to put these findings on your
program there are far too many but I
have attached them because I believe you
will find them very willing and they
will assist you in your own studies
regards Heather so this is an
interesting question and dilemma that
Heather presents to us Pastor what can
we say in regards to this uh apparent uh
understanding of Heather that God does
not have a physical body is not a person
or is an is not a men in the sense of a
male uh experience what can we say about
this well uh there's two issues here one
is that uh God is
genderless and uh the other is whether
God uh has a physical existence or not
and so we need to address both of those
uh not only does the bible use uh the
masculine gender to refer to God uh
because God is called father
uh and you know father that that's
masculine right um but also God has a
physical
existence uh the problem is that we have
be been impacted by Greek
philosophy you know we think uh that uh
you know having a body is a real problem
having a body isn't a problem the
problem is sin acting on the body right
so when there's no sin there's no issue
having a body right and so I think that
we need to address uh first of all the
gender thing uh in uh her question she
presents wisdom it appears several times
uh as being a w a physical woman but we
need to understand that this is speaking
in figurative language we need to be
careful when something speaks in
figurative language uh it can be you you
know Jesus used for example he says I
wanted to gather uh you as chicks as a
hen gathers her chicks with her well you
know that's feminine gender right so
Jesus is comparing uh himself with with
uh a chicken that is a feminine gender
but it's a figurative language it's not
literal language correct and another
thing interesting specifically about
wisdom is that uh wisdom is it's a
symbol of Christ as a matter of fact the
Apostle Paul in the first letter to the
Corinthians he defines with wisdom as
being Jesus himself notice what it says
there in verses 24 and verse 30 of 1
Corinthians 1 it says
there uh but to those who are called
both Jews and Greeks Greeks Christ the
power of God and the wisdom of God now
look at verse 30 it says there but of
him you are in Christ Jesus who became
for us wisdom from God and righteousness
and sanctification and Redemption in
other words we can notice that the Bible
even you know when we're going through
those passages in the Old Testament that
mention wisdom in a figurative language
they are actually speaking of Jesus
Apostle Paul calls wisdom is Jesus so
it's important to know that these
passages that are used as uh maybe
another gender are like you said just
figurative and the Fulfillment of wisdom
is Christ Christ is called in the Bible
Jesus and Christ of course is a man he
has a uh he's a male and has a body
nobody can go against that concept you
know Christ has a physical body he
became a man he became incarnated and
another thing that's interesting is that
when Jesus was with his disciples the
disciples asked they wanted to see the
Father and Jesus told them you know you
are if you see me right now physically
you're seeing me you're you're it's like
seeing the father so if Jesus was to say
if Jesus who is God would have thought
that the father has no physical body why
would he say that or lie that way you
know it's not that he's just talking you
know theoretically he's actually
speaking to the fact that if the
disciples have seen Christ I've seen the
Jesus as a as a savior as the Messiah as
a person as a being with a body so the
father has the same experience and like
you said pastor he asks us in the prayer
that we need to address God the father
as father as a as a father figure for to
us so it's important to keep that in
mind yeah there's a couple quotations
from the spirit of Prophecy that are
really helpful actually there's more
than a couple uh but I want to read the
first one is in the book education page
15 MH um and this is speaking about
creation so it's before the Incarnation
right it says here when Adam came from
the Creator's
hand he bore in his physical mental and
spiritual nature a likeness to his
maker
physical mental and spiritual a likeness
to his
maker so if Adam physically had the
likeness of his maker his maker must
have a physical nature right uh it
continues saying God created man in his
own image and it was his purpose that
the longer man lived the more fully he
should reveal his this image the more
fully reflect the glory of the Creator
mhm and then there's another statement
which is very interesting uh this is
after the
Incarnation uh Ellen White was taken
away in Vision uh the title of the
chapter is the termination of the 2300
days so that's 1844 MH and um Ellen
White described this in early writings
page 54 I saw a throne
and on it sat the father and the son
MH I gazed on jesus' countenance and
admired his lovely person yeah the
father's person I could not behold for a
cloud of Glorious light covered
him I asked Jesus if his father had a
form like
[Music]
himself he said he had but I could not
behold it for he said he if you should
once Behold The Glory of his person you
would cease to
exist Jesus is the image of his father
exactly and here in 1844 Ellen White is
envisioned she's asking you know Jesus
does your father have a form like you do
exactly and Jesus answers yes
because I am the image of my father mhm
so so the first statement education page
15 says that the father has a physical
nature as does Jesus and also here now
the problem is that when we hear the
word
Spirit immediately we think ghostly yeah
exactly immaterial or incorporeal like
like the question says um but that is
more Greek philosophy than concrete
Hebrew thinking mhm um you know we think
of the angels as Spirits because they're
called ministering Spirits right and so
you know the minute we hear the word
Spirits we say oh these are ghostly you
know they they don't have a body and
they're they're kind of like a a cloud
you know but but really
Satan has a physical
nature uh I want to read from early
writings page 152 this is a remarkable
statement Ellen White saw Satan Enis
vision yeah and notice notice what she
has to say on page 152 I was shown Satan
as he once was a happy exalted
Angel then I was shown him as he now is
he still Bears a kingly form so does he
have a form yes okay his
features he has features are still Noble
for he is an angel a fallen angel but
the expression of his countenance oh
does he have a countenance that's a face
of course is full of anxiety anxiety
care unhappiness malice hate Mischief
deceit and every evil that brow oh he
has a brow that brow which was once so
Noble I particularly noticed his
forehead oh he's got a
forehead his forehead commence from his
eyes oh he's got eyes too coming commen
from his eyes to
recede I saw that he had been so long
bent to evil that every good quality was
debased and every evil trait was
developed his eyes were cunning Sly and
showed great
penetration his
frame his frame was large but the
flesh hung Loosely about his hands and
face as I be held him his chin oh he's
got a chin too his chin was resting upon
his left hand oh he's got a left
hand he appeared to be in deep thought a
smile Oho he smiled so he must have lips
and he must have teeth right a smile was
upon his countenance which made me
tremble it was so full of evil and
satanic slightness this smile is the one
he wears just before he makes sure of
his victim and as he fastened the victim
in his snare this smile
grows wow
horrible all of the features all the
physical features ex she says she saw
him as he now is en Vision so do angels
have a physical nature yes their Spirits
not in the sense of being
incorporeal not in the sense of being
Ghostly and having no no material um
existence
uh but it's the fact that they're
Spiritual Beings mhm yeah it's kind of
like Jesus uh 1 Corinthians chapter 15
verse 42 to 45 it's a very interesting
passage uh maybe you can read that I've
been talking too much No 1 Corinthians
15 1 Corinthians 15 and verse 42- 45
it's I can read that for you Pastor Bor
says here it is sown in dis honor it is
verse 42 42 so also is there
resurrection of the death the body is
sown in corruption and it is raised in
incorruption it is sown in dishonor it
is raised in glory it is sown in
weakness it is raised in power it is
sown a natural body it is raised a
spiritual body there is a natural body
and there is a spiritual body okay so
the question
is are resurrected Saints going to have
a body yes what kind of body is it
called it's going to be the spiritual
body incorrupt does that mean that're
they're not going to have any flesh
they're going to be just like a ghost no
the evidences are clear in the Bible
that they have a body they have a
physical did Jesus
resurrect did Jesus have a body when he
resurrected let me put it that way oh
yes did what kind of body was it that's
a good question the question is that he
had a spiritual
body but but but he had Flesh and Bones
because he says you know touch me yeah
and then they gave him a fish to eat
exactly
so he must have a digestive system
exactly right yes so so so you know we
might we might be impacted by Greek
philosophy yeah and say you know a
spirit is something that is intangible
uh but the body you know is something
concrete but but that is Greek
philosophy yeah that is not the biblical
Concept in the Bible the body is
good but it's been impacted by sin
and and Paul of course later on in
chapter
15h uh he says behold I tell you a
mystery we shall not all sleep but we
shall be all be changed in a moment in
the twinkling of an eye at the last
trumpet for the trumpet trumpet will
sound and the dead will be raised
Incorruptible and we shall be changed MH
this corruptible must put on
incorruption and this Mortal must put on
immortality yeah so the only difference
is not that you don't have a body when
you resurrect it's a spiritual body yeah
in the sense that it's free from
corruption it's free from being able to
die it is free from from Death right um
and by the way uh when Satan is
destroyed uh the Bible tells us that he
will be reduced to ashes exactly now
what do you need to have in order to
have ashes you need to have a body you
have to have material exactly a material
presence uh so so you know the answer to
this question is don't be impacted by
Greek philosophy be impacted by what the
Bible says and don't get all hung up on
genders yeah you know there there can be
feminine figurative Expressions that are
applied to Jesus like the hen like
wisdom yeah that doesn't mean that he's
a woman right uh uh so so there are
there are genders clearly yeah amen amen
Pastor thank you for the answer we pray
that this will help Heather in her study
of the scriptures and now we have
another question well this is actually I
just want to read this is a sometimes we
receive some emails and that are kind of
like questions that are addressed to to
the ministry here to you or to the
pastors here but this one is important
because we like to also let to let
people know how um you know uh the Lord
is using the ministry to help others to
know better this understanding of the
scriptures I'll read this this letter
addressed to you it says Dear pastor
bour the reasoning which I'm writing you
pertains to my belonging to be more
knowledgeable to be more equipped with
the scriptures in the teaching and
teachings of Ellen White the spirit of
Prophecy and of course the sermons and
teachings of Pastor Steven bore
understanding that understanding that
according to the scriptures and that
there is no need for men to be taught
one another the word of God however the
enlightenment has been shed to the 7
Adventist movement and the fact that my
heart mind Mind and Spirit has longed to
preach the word of God through the most
explicit and profound and pure mannerism
as I have found through the above
mentioned teachings Lord provided I'll
be 57 this month yet I am a Layman uh in
quality when it comes to formal
education and some within my
congregation will look down upon me for
not being born into the movement
although it is disconcerting and
disheartening this has never dissuaded
me from speaking the truth as it has
been revealed to me since I began to
seek the word of God with my whole heart
and in conjunction with the spirit of
Prophecy Kenneth Cox May Rest In Christ
and Pastor s bore my seal is only
further height heightening for knowledge
and spiritual enlightenment that I
receive from you teachers and Educators
at secrets and seal and S TV I am a man
of simple needs and my lo my lifelong
desire is to preach the Gospel According
to Sol scriptura Ellen White and pastor
Steven B another gentleman uh known
Theologian is a fellow parisher of
friend of mine but I'm am so intrigued
by the vastness and throughness of your
theological approach and its fundamental
base of LG white my pleas is that you
Aid me with my quest for the equipping
of the scriptures and the hope and
prayer that I can become a valuable
teacher and preacher of the Gospel of
Jesus Christ so this is from uh Joseph
from Metford USA and we we thank Joseph
because I I think it's it's what we want
we want people everyone to know the
truth and to be persuaded to study
deeper and understand scriptures for
themselves and uh you know uh he's
requesting uh more material uh the good
news is that uh we have a secret
unsealed app yes and this would be a
good opportunity to encourage everyone
to download the app um you know you just
go to the uh Store and download the app
and you have access to all of our DVD
presentations also all of our study
notes all of the newsletters yes that
we've ever written everything that we've
ever produced is really on the app yeah
and so uh I would recommend that Joseph
by the way he lives uh he's writing from
Medford which is probably Medford
Oregon um I would encourage Joseph to
download the app if he hasn't yeah and
access all the material um we are very
pleased that uh that the ministry is
providing a need and uh we pray that the
Lord will continue to bless Joseph amen
amen and we thank for that wonderful
comment from him and letter um perhaps
we have Pastor I know few minutes to
answer this other question um that I
think is very important and is the
following it says and one shall say unto
him this from no nonat we don't know
from where but it says and one shall say
unto him what are the wounds in thy hand
hands then then shall he answer those
with which I was wounded in the house of
my friends most have believe that the
meaning of this verse is to indicate
that Jesus will be the only one not
perfect in heaven for he will retain the
scars in his hands in uh verses 1
through six of saniah 13 is often called
by many translators and translations as
a fountain of cleansing has been
described that a certain day will come
where the House of David will be
purified it says false prophets will be
no more and no one will ever try to
claim to claim false things verse six in
the end of the section and a question
was asked to a certain P person what
about those wounds in your hands from
this question steem the famous phrase I
was wounded in the house of my friend
immediately verses 7 and N talks about
the scattering of the sheep when the
shepherd had been strike two-third of
the sheep would die and only one third
Will Survive and purified I can
understand that the person in Zechariah
13:6 can be the same Shepherd that was
strike in Zechariah 137
however the famous conclusion about
being Jesus and not being perfect seems
to be a great leap of conclusion do we
have other references in the Bible and
spirit of Prophecy that will further
explain this so I think his question is
whether or not this is really about
Jesus or not what can we say about
that well you know it's a it's an
assumption to say that uh that Jesus is
going to be imperfect because he's going
to have the scars on his hands there's a
there's a dactic teaching reason why
he's going to have the scars on his
hands um I know that there's a quotation
that we have in the book great
controversy about uh that and perhaps
it' be a good idea to read that
absolutely it's from great
controversy uh page
674 it says there one reminder alone
remains as you mentioned is a teaching
reason a redeemer will ever bear the
marks of his crucifixion upon his
wounded head upon his side his hands and
feet are the only traces of the cruel
work that sin has wrought says the
prophet beholding Christ in his glory he
had bright beams coming out of his side
and there was and there was the hiding
of his power as habak habak
3:4 that peer side when flow the Crimson
stream of that reconciled men to God
there is the savior's Glory there is the
hiding of his power Mighty to Save
through the sacrifice of redemption he
was therefore strong to execute Justice
upon them them that despise God's mercy
and the tokens of his humiliation are
His Highest honor through the Eternal
ages the wounds of Calvary will show
forth his praise and declare his power
you know she actually quotes a very
important verse there mhm uh she's
quoting habc chapter 3 in verse 4
correct which is describing the second
coming mhm because it says there Lord I
have heard your speech and was afraid oh
Lord revive your work in the midst of
the years in the midst of the years make
it known in Wrath remember mercy God
came from Taman the Holy One from Mount
pan his glory covered the heavens and
the Earth was full of his praise His
brightness was like the light he had
Rays flashing for from his hand and
there his power was hidden amen Ellen
White quotes that verse and she speaks
when it says that the glory shines from
his hand it's talking about the wounds
in his hands right um and also you know
Zechariah uh there's the question as to
where whether Zechariah uh 13 uh chapter
uh 136 and 7 applies to Christ the New
Testament does that amen well we thank
you for time we look forward to seeing
you here next time God bless you and
keep you safe
[Music]